こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
月日はもう２月・・・
気づけばもうすぐ
ヴァレンタインデー
いますか？
今回はですね、みなさん
ご存じでしょうか
あの赤いパッケージのキットカット
多分ご存じだと思うんですけども
今回そのキットカットを作っているネスレさんが
ハァｯッフﾝッ
なんとですね
そのサービスを使う事によって
おねだりしたり　送ったりすることが出来るらしいです
ふぉーーーーーーーーーーーｯ！
はい という訳でこちらですね
バレンタインポスト
これね～ 結構いいと思うんだよね～
実際多分このチョコレートあげるの恥ずかしいって女の子もいると思うから
そういう子がね
男子にね、こう 気持ちを伝えたい時に
こっそり伝えちゃってもいいのかなって思います
キラーン☆
(↖)ということで
もしその遠くに想いを伝えたい人がいるんだったら、このバレンタインポストで
ピュッと送っちゃってもいいのかなと思います
(↖)という訳でなんとこれ
バーチャルだけじゃなくて ひょっとしたら
という訳でさっそくやってみましょう
【ツイッターで作る】
【どのポストにする？】
まあ色んなポストがいるわけですね
【ポストボーイ】
【友だち大好き、チョコ大好き！】
【誰にでもすぐおねだりするよ】
こういう感じで色んなポストがいるんですけど
僕はァ！！！！
【熱血ポスト】でいきます
なんか、、頑張ってる感じが好きです
このポストにしましょう
こういう感じでポストをつくります
【ポストをシェアしてチョコをおねだりしよう！】
これで、Ｆａｃｅｂｏｏｋ・ツイッター・ＬＩＮＥでこの画像がシェアされます
はい！もうツイートしたら終わりです！こんな感じになります
みんなぁ～～
チョコ クレ ヨォ～～～～～～
そして更に今回は
私の誕生日記念として特別企画！！
この僕に
あの、、リアルなチョコを送れるみたいです～！
アゥアゥアゥヌァウ　ありがとうございます！
恐れ多いです、ほんと、恐れ多いです
リアルチョコを僕に送れるみたいなんですけど～ちょっとやってみましょう
バレンタインポストのね、ここだ
【人気Youtuberにチョコを贈ろう！】
お待ちしております！！
さ～て、バレンタインポストでおねだりもしたし
誰かチョコレートくれねえかな～
私はなーんてモテるんだ！！！！！！
ハッハッハッハッハーー！！！
モテすぎてモテすぎて仕方ないZE！！
でもそれにしても多いな！！！
こっちに
こちら
送られてきました
チョコラトリーサブリムビターを食べたことないのでちょっと食べてみます
すごいなんか
おお～～！
キットカットですね～
いただきます
ん～～～～～！！！
うまい！うまいぞ！！
めちゃくちゃ甘いってわけじゃないんですけど
ほのかに甘くて～ なんか
ビターが美味しく感じるっていうことは・・・
私も大人になったな
キラッ
ああ～やっぱりチョコレートを食うと元気が出るな～～～～
けど１人じゃ全部食べれません
はい という訳でですね～
１人だとこれだけの量のチョコレートは食べきれないので～
ちょっと今ここにあるチョコレートを、僕が今
達がいます！！
今回そのチョコレートをその人たちに届けたいと思います!
みなさん『U-FES』というイベントはご存じでしょうか？
去年から全国を回ってて、
それのラストが東京で行われます
でね～僕知ってるんですよ
僕とか参加者のクリエイターさんはもちろんなんですけども
その裏で僕の事務所で働いている社員さんや
イベントの関係者の皆さん
裏方のスタッフ
普段見えない人たちが凄い努力して
初めて成り立ってるイベントでございます
普段表には出ないね、裏方で頑張ってくださってる皆様に
僕は最後 元気を渡したいと思っているので
ここにあるチョコレートを全部渡す
わけにはいきません！！！！(いかないんかーい)
全部渡しませんｗｗｗｗｗｗ
こっちの赤いほうね
１０００個の部分は、僕が友達とか後輩とか食べる分にして、
こっちのショコラトリーサブリムビターが残り９９個あるので
こちらの９９個のサブリムビターを
寝る間も惜しんで頑張っている方もいるみたいなので
甘いチョコレートを食べて、少しでも元気をだしてくれればと思います
では！行ってきます！！！！！
はい、というわけで
キットカット配っていきたいと思います！
は)いつもお疲れ様です　ス)ありがとうございます
は)いつもお疲れ様です　ヒ)え～ありがとう
ヒ)キットカットだぁ～超嬉しい
ありがとうございます
(１人１人に渡すはじめん)
は)いつもお疲れ様です　ス)ありがとうございます
は)ビターが美味しいので、ぜひ食べてください
は)ＣＨＵ　ス)ＣＨＵ
は)いつもお疲れ様です　鎌)あーとーざいます！
は)渋い鎌田さんにおすすめの一品です　鎌)ははははｗｗ
お！uuumイチのイケメンです
は)いつもお疲れ様です イ)あ！ありがとうございます
ス)ありがとうございま～～す 頂きます
は)失礼します(シュタッ)
はいというわけで全部配りきりました！
えーと、みなさん喜んでくれてよかったです
そしてですね、
いつも動画をみてくださっている皆さんにも
私からバーチャルチョコを贈りたいと思います
たくさんの方に受け取ってもらえると嬉しいです！
特に男子ぃ！！♡
ＣＨＵ
うぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇえええええ
はいという訳でみなさん
私が今日紹介したバレンタインポスト
「絶対うちチョコレートなんて渡せない！」とか
「おおお俺チョコレートなんていらねえしぃ」みたいな
ちょっと突っ張っている女子や男子の皆さん！
想いを伝えてみてはいかがでしょうか
ぜひ皆さんもチョコをゲットしてもらえると嬉しいです
じゃあな！！
♪～　エンディング